ام
اهلا بكم اجتمع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
جون كيري مع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو في القدس الغربيه للمره
الثانيه خلال اقل من اربع وعشرين ساعه
يسعى كان خلال جولته الى تقريب وجهات
النظر بين الطرفين الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني
بهدف اعاده اطلاق مفاوضات السلام بينهما
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
هل يحمل وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في جولته
جديدا يتيح استئناف مفاوضات السلام
ما مدى استعداد الطرفين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي
للتجاوب مع جهوده في ظل واقع متغير داخليا
واقليميا
لم يكشف جون كيري وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الكثير عن خططه لدفع الطرفين الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني لاستئناف مفاوضات السلام
واكتفى بالتصريح بانه لم يكن ليعود الى
المنطقه دون قناعه بامكانيه احراز تقدم
لكن الاسرائيليين استبقوا جولته المكوكيه
الخامسه في الشرق الاوسط بالاعلان عن بناء
وحدات استيطانيه جديده وبالتاكيد على ان
الامن شرط اساسي لوجود اسرائيل كما اشاروا
الى ان نجاح مهمه كيري مرهون بموقف الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس
هي الجوله الخامسه لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي جون كيري في المنطقه ولا تزال
الجهود المتعلقه ب عوده الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين لطاوله المفاوضات تراوح
مكانها يسيطر الترقب الحذر على صعود
المنطقه المختلفه ولا تعلم الدول الرئيسيه
شكل اسبابها المرتقب في الامر و امكانيه
نجاح الكريم في اعاده الجانبين للمفاوضات
المتوقفه منذ اكتوبر عام الفين وعشره بسبب
الخلاف الكبير حول سياسات اسرائيل
الاستيطانيه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو يتجاهل هذا الامر ويصر
على ان امن اسرائيل اولا وان تكون الدوله
الفلسطينيه القادمه في اطار حال لدولتين
المفتاح منزوعه السلاح
ويلوح متمسكه بمطالب اسرائيل الامنيه ولو
خصما على جهود السلام الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس لم يغير موقفه الرافض لاي
تفاوض ما لم يتوقف بناء المستوطنات في
الاراضي المحتله وين به المفاوضون
الفلسطينيون الى ان بناء المستوطنات داخل
القدس الشرقيه وحولها يقضي تماما على حل
الدولتين
فبدون القدس الشرقيه لن تكون هناك دوله
فلسطينيه الغموض يلف الموقف كله ويكثر
الان متقارب جديد يطرح كان للطرفين وذلك
باقناع هما بعقد اجتماعات بين عباس
ونتنياهو بحضوره بحيث لا تعتبر مفاوضات
مباشره بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين بل
تكون تحضيرا للمفاوضات الرئيسيه لكن
علامات استفهام كثيره تحيط بهذه الصيغه و
فرص نجاحها يقال ان الاسرائيليين وافقوا
عليها و تمارس ضغوط على عباس الموافقه وان
الوزير الامريكي ادخل الان في مساعي
تشجيعات تبلورت سابقا عبر اللجنه الرباعيه
الدوليه و يتم بموجبها ضخ استثمارات
للفلسطينيين تقدر ب 4 مليارات دولار
امريكي الثابت حتى الان ان الموقف جامد
كما كان نتائج مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات
ولا يستطيع تاكيد موافقه الجانبين على
مجرد اللقاء ولكنه يطمح حسب تصريحاته
الاخيره في الكويت لتحقيق التقدم الملحوظ
قبل انعقاد الدوره الجديده للجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده في سبتمبر المقبل
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من رام
الله اياد البرغوثي الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي من واشنطن ماتيوس المحلل السياسي
في مركز التقدم الامريكي
ومن القدس داني روبنشتاين استاذ الاعلام
في الجامعه العبريه اهلا بالضيوف الكرام
وابدا مع ضيفي من واشنطن السيد
سيد اس صحف اسرائيليه توقعت ان اقصى ما
يمكن حقيقه السيد كيري هو ان يجمع بين
الرئيس عباس وبين رئيس الوزراء اه نتنياهو
هل هذا مؤشر ايجابي بالنسبه للجانب
الامريكي فيما يتعلق ب استئناف مفاوضات
السلام
قادر فعليا على تحمل عباس ونتنياهو الى
طاولات المفاوضات وسوف يكون في ذلك امر
ايجابي هذا ما حاول الرئيس امام القيام به
عندما توقفت الجوله الفائته لكن اه الوزير
كان واضح جدا ان هذه المحادثات ليست هدفا
بحد ذاته علينا النصر الى محادثاته هدفا
لغرض وهو طبعا
الوصول الى حل النزاع اذن جمعهم في طاوله
امر جيد لكن لابد من المزيد سيد اياد يقول
بانه لو لم تكن هناك مؤشرات ايجابيه لما
عدت الى المنطقه في هذه الجوله هل تعتقد
بانه يحمل جديدا
اه انا لا اعتقد انه يحمل جديدا الى
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين هو ربما يحمل
جديدا فيما يتعلق بملف المنطقه انا
باعتقادي ان الملف الاهم الان لدى
الامريكيين هو ما يجري في سوريا وبالتالي
اه
الانشطه التي تتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه هي
لمحاوله معالجه الاثار الجانبيه التي اه
تحدث فيما لو حدث تدخل اكبر من الولايات
المتحده فيما يتعلق سوريا سيد روبنشتاين
الاسر او الجانب الاسرائيلي استبق وصول
كيري الى المنطقه بال بالحديث عن ايضا
مشاريع استيطانيه جديده
هل معنى ذلك هذا توقعا او ارتقابا لما قد
يحمله كبير في هذه الجوله
بالنسبه لاسرائيل في تشاؤم يعني ما فيه
امل الاستئناف في المواجهه السلام وانا
باعتقد بالنسبه للحكومه اسرائيل كل
المشكله هيدي هي يعني من يحمل المسؤوليه
اه بالفشل الاستئناف المفاوضات بين
اسرائيل محمود عباس الرئيس الفلسطيني هو
المسؤول هو يعني هو
استئناف المفاوضات في اسرائيل وفي شروط
فلسطينيه وهذا مرفوض كاملا
سيد
ما الذي يختلف عما قامت به وزيره الخارجيه
الى كلينتون وما قد يقوم به السيد كيري
حتى يمكن البناء على احداث اختراق في هذا
الانسداد في عمليه السلام
اعتقد ان فقه اساسيا هو ان جهود الوزير
التالي الراميه الى اه
اعاده اطلاق المبادره العربيه ايضا وحاول
ان يدفع الجامعه العربيه الى تعديل ربما
هذه المبادره او النظر فيها واه ادخال بعض
القضايا لم تكن في النسخه الاولى من
مبادرات السلام وكانت اسرائيل قد اشارت
الى هواجسها بشانها اذا ما يحمله الوزير
الى المحادثات اليوم هي اشاره واضحه ايضا
من دعما من بلدان عربيه كثيره هذه
شرعها ولكن طبعا يبقى غياب الثقه سيد اياد
اذا وفق الجانب الامريكي في جمع الرئيس
عباس مع نتنياهو
هل يعتبر هذا النجاح في حد ذاته
هذا يعتبر النجاح للولايات المتحده
واسرائيل اذا تراجع اه الرئيس ابو مازن عن
شرط وقف الاستيطان بشكل كامل ولم يوجد اي
اه ما يشير الى اه قبول الجانب الاسرائيلي
ولو خطوه ايجابيه ولو شكليا هذا صحيح
سيحرج الرئيس ابو مازن امام شعبه وامام اه
كافه شعوب المنطقه و ب باعتقادي انه لن
يقبل على هذا الموضوع دون اي مؤشر ايجابي
فيما يتعلق بالاستيطان بالذات وب ملفات
اخرى في القضيه المعتقلين نفس السؤال
اطرحه على ضيفه السيد روبين شتاين في حال
وفق الجانب الامريكي في الجمعه بين الرئيس
عباس وبين نتنياهو هل هذا مؤشر ايجابي
بنظركم
هذا ايجابي مع ما في اي نتيجه الاجتماع
اعداء اجتماع بالبدايه اجتماع
الموضوع هذا موضوع في انا بعتقد في
باي شيء واحد وهذا افراج ال الاسرى
بالنسبه للحدود
للانسحاب الاسرائيلي الحدود
وستين ما في امل ما في اي تقدم بالنسبه
لهذا يعني الحكومه الاسرائيليه عده حكومه
يمينيه وفي الحكومه الاسرائيليه في اه في
حزب المستوطنين مع ما نفتالي بينت يعني ما
فيه احتمالها اي تقدم
اما في احتمالات قد بالنسبه لافراج الاسرى
الاسرى الموجودين في السجن الاسرائيلي من
قبل اوسلو نحكي على المائه وعشرين اسرى
وانا بعتقد ولا قرار بالامور بالنسبه
الاسرائيلي اسرائيل ما بتخسر اي شيء اذا
بدو اما بالنسبه لل ابو مازن هذا بيكون
يعني رجع كبير افراج ال الاسرى
العصر ما فيه انا باعتقد ما فيه اه اه امل
لاي تقادم
سيدرس يعاب على الجانب الامريكي على الاقل
من الجانب العربي والجانب الفلسطيني بانه
لم يكن ابدا وسيطا نزيها بين الطرفين او
متوازنا في طرحه بين الطرفين يضغط كل
الضغط على الجانب الفلسطيني ولا يقوم باي
ضغوط على الجانب ال الاسرائيلي اذن
وبالتالي كيف يمكن الحديث عن اي مبادره عن
اي دور امريكي وهذه هي صوره الامريكيه لدى
الطرف الفلسطيني والطرف العربي
اعتقد ان هذا الانتقاد بمحله لا اعتقد انه
غير منصف ولا سيما في الطريقه التي تعاملت
فيها الولايات المتحده واداره اوباما مع
هذا الموضوع وتراجعت عن طالبها بوقف
الاستيطان على مدى السنوات الفائته
وان استمرار بناء الوحدات الاستيطانيه
ولا سيما اذا الاحرى اعلان المحرج عن هذه
النشاطات الاستيطانيه في كل مره نسمع عنها
هذا يحرج اذا ان الامريكيين وهذا ما راينا
قبل بضعه ايام خلال زياره الوزير كاري
واعلن في الوقت عينه عن نشاطات استيطانيه
جديده هذا مسيئه جدا فعلا الى مصداقيه
الولايات المتحده لكن الحجه المبادره لذلك
اعتقد على الرغم مما ذكرته قبل قليل هو ان
الولايات المتحده تبقى الشريك او على
الاقل اللاعب الوحيد في هذه المفاوضات
الذي يمكن ان يضمن امن اسرائيل و يمكن
فعلا ان يحمل اسرائيل الى طاوله المفاوضات
اذن في ما اقره بوجهه هذه الانتقادات
والولايات المتحده لم تكن ربما كما قلت
لاعبا منصفا وعادلا اعتقد انا قيمتها
كوسيط اساسيا هنا بالغ الاهميه سيد اياد
يقول البعض بان خطه تقوم على الشكل التالي
اجراء لقاء او لقاءين بين الجانب
الفلسطيني والجانب الاسرائيلي اه اه
بينهما بشان بحضور الوزير كيري على ان
يكون اللقاء الثالث بين الرئيس عباس وبين
نتنياهو ضيفي من القدس اشار قبل قليل
موضوع رب امكانيه الافراج عن بعض السجناء
الفلسطينيين او الاسرى الفلسطينيين في
السجون الاسرائيليه
كيف ترى هذه الصيغه هذه او هذا الشكل
لقاءات ثنائيه او ثلاثيه ثم لقاء ثنائي
وهناك مبادرات اسرائيليه بالافراج عن بعض
الفلسطيني هل هي كافيه حتى يلتقي الرئيس
عباس مع نتنياهو
هو اه ليس المهم الشكل الصحيح المهم هو
الاستجابه على الاقل لبعض اه مطالب
الفلسطينيين
اه فيما يتعلق بالاستيطان وكما قلنا اه
فيما يتعلق بموضوع اه الاسرى انا باعتقادي
ان اه اسرائيل تصبح اه اقل اعتمادا على
الولايات المتحده الان الاسرائيليه هي
دوله
فيها الغاز وامكانيه وجود النفط وبالتالي
اه على الولايات المتحده ان تدرك انها في
المستقبل سيكون امكانيه ان تضغط فان تكبح
جماح اليمين الاسرائيلي هي اه اقل
وبالتالي عليها ان تستغل الفرصه الان اذا
ارادت ان تنجز اه اي اه تقدم الان
الفلسطينيون جاهزون ل لمفاوضات اه هم
يعلمون تماما ان المفاوضات هي السبيل
الوحيد لحل القضيه الفلسطينيه ولكن اه ليس
ضمن الشروط الاسرائيليه وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بالاستيطان اشرت الى موضوع الاستيطان
السيد اه روبنشتاين الجانب الاسرائيلي
ابدى استعداده للجلوس مع الطرف الفلسطيني
بالحضور الامريكيه ولكنه يستبق زياره كيري
بمشاريع استيطانيه جديده اذن كيف يكون
الجانب الاسرائيلي جدا في هذه الخطوه وهو
يقوم بخطوات تفجر اي لقاءات بينه وبين
الجانب الفلسطيني
اه بالنسبه لحكومه اسرائيل قبل اربع سنين
اسرائيل وقفت الاستيطان حركه
الفتره انا بعتقد العشره الشهور وشكرا من
النتيجه النتيجه تنسف من استئناف
المفاوضات
وهذا يعني مع اليوم اسرائيل ترفض انا انا
انه
الحكومه السريه اسرائيل ترفض اي وفي
الحركه ال حركه اللبونه وكل
المستوطنين اسرائيل بدها توصل المستوطنات
توصيل المستوطنات كل الوقت وهذا هدف في
الحكومه اسرائيل افضليه بينت هو يعني وزير
مهم في ال في الحكومه وقال ونحن بالنسبه
النا كل المفاوضات هذا كلام فادي نحن نبني
ونبدا وهذا التوصيل المستوطنات بالنسبه لل
وقف الاستيطان انا باعتقد ما في اي احتمال
ال وقف المستوطنات
في الجزء اثار هذه الحلقه سوف نتناول ما
الذي تغير داخليا واقليميا
ويمكن ان يؤثر بشكل مباشر على صيغه اي
لقاءات تصب في اتجاه اعاده الطرفين الى
طاوله المفاوضات بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش جهود وزير الخارجيه الامريكي جون
كيري لاستئناف مفاوضات السلام الاسرائيليه
الفلسطينيه
وجدد تحيه لضيوفي من القدس ورام الله
وكذلك من واشنطن الى ضيفي في القدس في رام
الله السيد اياد اشرت قبل قليل بان السبب
الاساسي لما يقوم به وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي هو ما يجري في المنطقه وبالتالي
الى اي مدى ما يجري في المنطقه يؤثر بشكل
مباشر عن اي حديث عن فرص السلام بين
الجانب الفلسطيني والجانب الاسرائيلي
يعني اذا اخذنا ما جرى اه قبيل غزو العراق
كان هناك اه
المشاريع التي حدثت فيما يتعلق بالمفاوضات
اه بين العرب والفلسطينيين من جهه
والاسرائيليين من الجهه اه القضيه
الفلسطينيه الان هي ليست اه محور اه
اهتمام وليست ضاغطه اه لا على الولايات
المتحده ولا على اسرائيل حتى يكون هناك اه
تقدم جدي باتجاه ايجاد حلول لها وبالتالي
انا باعتقادي كما قلت محاوله تطويق الاثار
الجانبيه التي قد تحدث من ايات انفجارات
قد توجد في المنطقه اه قد يكون هذا نذير
لتدخل اكبر اه امريكي فيما يجري في اه
الدول المحيطه وخاصه في سوريا
والفلسطينيون والقضيه الفلسطينيه هي دائما
يجب ان تكون اه تحت الرقابه حتى لا يكون
هناك اي اصابه هناك الفلسطينيون في لبنان
هناك امكانيه تكون مشاكل اه اكبر في
المنطقه
واعتقد ان اه لا يوجد شيء جدي فيما يتعلق
بحل القضيه الفلسطينيه بذاته السيد في
واشنطن هل تعتقد مثل ما يقول ضيفي في رام
الله بان هناك ارتباطا وثيقا بين هذه
الجوله وبين ما يجري في المنطقه وتحديدا
على مستوى الملف السوري
اعتقد ان
سوريا
ايضا بالنسبه لاسرائيل
والهدف طبعا هو تداعيات هذا الملف على امن
اسرائيل لكن يجب ان نفهم ان تحليل اداره
اوباما
امنيه
الملف الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني وضروره حل هذه
الازمه مازال يؤثر ايضا على الو كيف يؤثر
ذلك على المصالح الامريكيه هذا لم يتغير
حتى عندما راينا الربيع العربي والثورات
العربيه
قيل ان ربما القضيه الفلسطينيه سوف تصبح
اقل اهميه وان الاداره اليوم اضطر انا في
ذلك اهميه ما زالت قائمه ولابد من تمكين
المجموعات السكانيه في كل المنطقه
وبالتالي تكون هذه المجموعات قادره على
صنع قراراتها وايضا ارائها بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده ويكون ذلك قائما ايضا
على ملف القضيه الفلسطينيه اذن اداره ام
ما زالت في تحريرها تعتبر انه من المهم
جدا بالنسبه لمصالح الولايات المتحده
واهدافها انتصر الى حل لهذه الازمه وانهاء
الاحتلال سيد روبنشتاين العوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات هي رغبه امريكيه بالاساس ولكن
هل هي ايضا رغبه اسرائيليه
اه لا انا بعد انا بعد كل يوم الجرائد
الاسرائيليه وبالنسبه الى اخبار الملف
الفلسطينيه مش موجوده للدوله اه العناوين
اليوم مثلا بالجرائد الاسرائيليه بال بال
احضار اه شو صار في ال في في سوريا الحرب
في سوريا
والاخلاص في في مصر والله الفلسطينيين هذا
يعني مش الله الطاوله
يعني ما في
هذا باسرائيل اليوم انا باعتقد نفس الاشي
في الشارع الفلسطيني الفلسطيني لا احد
بالنسبه للمستقبل ما فيه احتمال اقامه
الدوله الفلسطينيه ولحاله دولتين هذا راحت
هذا كان بالسابق يعني خلال دولتين حل
دولتين اليوم ما في احتمال دولتين
في البديل الوحيد الدولتين هذا الدوره
واحده واسرائيل بيحكوا بالشريعه بيجوز
الزعماء بكم
استئناف المفاوضات ان يصدر الشعب بالنسبه
للشعب الاسرائيلي بيحكوا
اه نعمل شو
بيكون المستقبل اذا فيه دوله واحده
لاسرائيل والفرنسيين في دور واحد في كل
فلسطين هذا اليوم الموضوع الموجود الطاوله
بال بالحوار الاسرائيلي طيب هذا بالنسبه
للجانب الاسرائيلي ماذا عن الجانب
الفلسطيني سيد اياد اذا كان الانقسام
مازال هو العنوان الاكبر في الساحه
الفلسطينيه يضاف له عن ما جرى على مستوى
الحكومه ورئاسه الوزراء في اه اه في
فلسطين وبالتالي هل ايضا الحديث الان
والعوده الى المفاوضات يشكل عنوان اساسي
اهم بالنسبه للجانب الفلسطيني يجب ان يطرح
الان ويطلب من الامريكي ان يسعى فيه
هو انا اعتقد انها اه اداره سياسيه يوميه
وليس اكثر من ذلك يعني اه لا اعتقد انه اه
يوجد تفاؤل فلسطيني ان المفاوضات تسجيل
قريبا وان اسرائيل ستستجيب لبعض المطالب
الفلسطينيه اه المطلب الاساس هو مطلب
امريكي امريكا هي التي تريد ان يعود
الطرفان اه الى المفاوضات وان يجري الحديث
عن حل الدولتين وامريكا كما قلت هي تخشى
من تداعيات ما يجري في اه المنطقه
وتداعيات هذه اه هذه التداعيات ليست
بالضروره على القضيه الفلسطينيه وليست
بالضروره على من اسرائيل ربما على دول
اخرى محيطه وانا باعتقادي الاردن قد يكون
مهددا من قبل اليمين الاسرائيلي فيما لو
اه ذهبت الامور في سوريا وفي المنطقه الى
اه حيث لا تتوقع الولايات المتحده ومن هنا
هو ليس اكثر من ضبط ما يجري اه في المنطقه
وليس سير جدي باتجاه السلام سيد اس ماذا
لو فشل السيد كبيره في جمع الطرفين او
احداث اي اختراق
اعتقد اننا سوف نشهد تدهورا مستمرا في
الضفه الغربيه و سوف نشهد ايضا اه احتمالا
اكبر
حصول انتفاضه جديده
ضد السلطه الفلسطينيه على قدر ان تكون هذه
الانتفاضه الاسرائيليين وسوف تخسر ايضا
السلطه الفلسطينيه الثقه هي اصلا تبلي
بلاءا حسنا في استطلاعات الراي قد نشهد
واضح ان ايضا عفوا اكتساب حماس لمزيد من
المنطقيه ضد اه فتح بالتالي اذا لم نشهد
اي تقدم فان ايا من اثر ذلك سوف يكون
ايجابيا من وجهه نظري اعتقد ان هذه الحاله
وكما قلت قبل قليل ان تحليل اداره اوباما
لهذا الموضوع وايضا وزير الخارجيه الكريم
على الشكل التالي نحن نعيش فعلا عند حافه
الهاويه هنا واذا لم يحقق اي تقدم هنا
فانا تكون سيئه وقد كان تنسيق قائمه ايضا
الولايات المتحده اللي هو مع الفلسطينيين
ايضا في الضفه الغربيه لكن في الافق اذا
لم نجد اي امل لانهاء الاحتلال او لتحقيق
اي تقدم
فبالتالي ا قد نشهد
نوع من المراره التي سوف تؤدي الى نوع من
الانفجار والعنف سيد روبنشتاين هل من
مصلحه الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان تنجح ان
تفشل مهمه السيد
اه بالنسبه لاسرائيل
الاستئناف المفاوضات تجري المفاوضات هذا
مش الهدف الهدف هي الخلل
اللي بيمثل المفاوضات نحن في مفاوضات خلال
نحن نفاوض مع الفلسطينيين خلال اكثر من
عشرين سنه والشوبك ان النتيجه
يعني بالنسبه النا هذا المشكله شو بيصير
المستقبل شو الخال اه عبد الواقع في توصيل
مستوطنات وفي اليوم انا باعتقد اليوم
الناس بيحكوا على الدوله واحده من شانه
دولتين
وتجديد
استئناف المفاوضات هذا مش الهدف
سيد اياد هل تعتقد بان يضغط الجانب
الامريكي على الجانب الفلسطيني من خلال
وعودا ومن خلال اه دول اقليميه او وسائل
الضغط الامريكيه المعروفه حتى يجلس الجانب
الفلسطيني مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
اه انا لا اعتقد ذلك تعودنا ان يكون الضغط
على الجانب الفلسطيني
واه في تقريركم ذكرتم انك تتحدث عن
استثمارات باربعه مليارات دولار في
المناطق الفلسطينيه وعن الامن الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي هم يعتبرون القضيه الفلسطينيه هي
قضيه الاقتصاد ويمكن اه تجميدها على الاقل
لفتره طويله والظروف المعين اه لا
الانتفاضه ولا لاي حركات جديه اه ضد
الاحتلال هم ينتظرون
والاسرائيليون اه صحيح غير معنيين تماما
كما قال داني باي مفاوضات ولا باي حلول
الحاليه شكرا ل ضيوفي الكرام السيد اياد
البرغوثي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كنت معنا
من رام الله كما اشكر ضيفي من واشنطن ما
تدرس المحلل السياسي في مركز التقدم
الامريكي
واشكر ضيفي من القدس داني روبنشتاين ال
استاذ الاعلام في الجامعه العبريه
بدا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده في
ما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء باذن الله
ام
نعم